all right welcome everybody i'm excited
to have another
chess lesson today in preparation for my
pog
champs ii participation i've been doing
lessons with
uh levy rosman and alexandra botez
and eric rosen i've got people uh
from leeches and chess.com contacting me
and saying
i'll give you lessons my husband will
give you lessons my wife will give you
lessons
my eight-year-old kid who's clearly
better than you we'll give you lessons
as well
but i think lessons probably with these
three
um is going to be uh
good good for me i don't know how much
lessons i can do
so we're going to be joining levy
momentarily
i'm monitoring his stream very very
closely very powerfully and it looks
like he's dancing right now
so we'll see about that um i don't know
how much chess is happening i do also
have
i might just go over this tomorrow but i
was sent david pakman show bingo
instead of trump briefing bingo so this
would be
actually related to the david pakman
show
it's pretty damn funny and i have some
thoughts about some of these whether
these are really like the key ones that
should be on david pakman bingo oh is
can people not hear me is that so is
that a thing hold on
i want to make sure am i too low
anybody know a couple people are saying
i'm low
high very low very high yeah it seems
good in my uh
on in my elements of audio it seems good
so anyway i think that
there's some pretty funny stuff here and
um
yeah i don't know maybe i don't know
that we're gonna go through this uh
right now
but we will eventually so i'm gonna
actually just try to get
a hold of levy right now
and then we'll see what's going i might
as well just jump into it i mean there
have just been so many streams lately
that i don't i don't even have that much
stuff
to talk about um that i need to talk
about separately we might as well just
jump into the the chess stuff
and i'm also thinking the i've been
doing twitch only on these it's been
occurring to me that maybe i would do
these
um on youtube as well i just don't know
that the youtube
um audience is as into live chess stuff
but i've been posting them after the
fact so there's just a lot of questions
and a lot of strategy about
what the right way to do the chess stuff
should be some people are asking for
chess everywhere others are saying i
really just like
politics stuff on youtube and you know i
know i can go to twitch live if i want
to get involved in that i don't know
what the right thing is it's all
strategy
it's all strategy um i'm noticing i just
have
endless now that i'm on chess.com
um wow there's just i'm having
endless endless messages about chess
from people who want to coach me
i mean the thing is it's like how much
coaching can i really do
if i have three coaches already and i've
got to play some games and do some
puzzles it's like i'm still running my
show full-time you know i don't know
that i'm
able to do um quite quite so much
so let's let's check in with uh levy and
see what's going on
let's see let me admit him to the
meeting first
okay i think this is what's going i
think he's pulling me in now
gonna be a little bit of tours for a
second here but i don't want to leak uh
i don't want to leak the meeting yeah we
definitely don't want any
any leaking happening that's for sure if
something leaked it would be just
horrible
um david can you hear me oh hey yes i
can let me start let me get everything
going here very powerfully
i see you in a suit right now i see a
picture of you in a suit
oh that yeah that's baby me um and for
some reason i changed that picture
repetitively and
nothing nothing changes so
i don't know i don't know why that's the
case okay i you are going to look
hilarious in my window
for a second um gotta crop you
whoa there's two of you now at some
point
my audience will want to see you oh
there you go okay now yes now i see you
okay good
yeah i'm camera shy after the first
lesson so
hey i was monitoring your chat very
closely just to see if there was
anything uh
interesting that that may be a catalyst
for conversation do you speak hebrew
uh no no no i i did have a bar mitzvah
uh okay
but i i just learned how to say my my
verse thing it's not a psalm that's
that's from the that's from the other
holy book
that's not our thing song yeah i don't
know we don't we don't do that
[Laughter]
got it but what what it's a verse sort
of like a
i believe it's a torah verse yeah i
think that's the way it is
um one thing i i forgot to bring this up
before but i believe there's
also an argentinian-american uh
i don't know if he's if he's also he
might be jewish but he he might not
robert hungaski is a chess grand master
he's actually also from argentina
um robert hungovsky let's look that up
that's that's interesting
i'm not familiar i know that there have
been some notable argentinian
players uh let's see what we can find
about robert hangoski
why don't i have a chessboard that seems
important for a chess lesson
is there a wiki for robert hongosky
not seeing one there we go okay
professional it says professional chess
player and coach from united states born
in stamford connecticut because is this
that doesn't sound argentinian i'm
fairly certain he
he either he has like a whole he lived
in argentina i think he was born in
argentina
that could be he claims to have been
born in stamford connecticut
what okay uh disregard
i mean i i'm like because the thing is
okay maybe
he has a whole family in argentina and
he moved to argentina and grew up in
argentina that might be
that could be that could be that could
be something i'm trying to see who are
the notable
are you familiar with the argentinian
chess tragedy
oh no i'm not either i don't know i
don't want it to bum me out but i'm
sorry let's see
gothenburg sweden in 1955
there were a bunch of argentinians who
were scheduled to play many jewish
argentinians
and what is the tragedy exactly oh no
this
oh i think the tragedy might just be
that a lot of them lost
yeah okay i was thinking it was going to
be that somebody died
uh a lot of people lost okay well that's
less i mean i'm glad nobody died but
it's an embarrassment for argentina
brain cells might have might have been
lost um
okay uh i'm i'm almost done david i'm
going to put
a middle game lesson because i feel like
we
with you with you
uh last time we put 1100 elo so since
our last lesson you've picked up 200
points right
god i can't imagine that's true no i
don't think so
i don't think i've picked i've lost more
games than i've won to be perfectly
frank
okay so we'll we'll we'll we'll talk
about that the good thing is
that um at least now we have some you
know official announcement so
obviously you you will be you'll be
taking part in in pogchamps too i think
we'll
i don't i'm not responsible for
scheduling or those kinds of things and
but that we'll we'll figure all that out
logistically
uh talk to me about what you've done
chest-wise i know you did one lesson
with eric and i think another lesson
with alexandra
that's right what did you i watched
actually a lot of it i had you and eric
on in the background while i was doing
some stuff so
it was mostly just arguing about whether
you're teaching me the right stuff
okay wow no i'm kidding it really wasn't
by the way hold on i do want to get
there
i'm trying to figure out is there music
playing in your room
no but my ac is on oh okay i'm just
cause i'm wondering if it's my phone
mate something okay if that's what it is
that's fine
do you hear some sort of white noise or
it's not a white noise it sounds
it's like a squealing almost and i don't
know if it's in my system i don't even
know if my audience can hear it
that that doesn't sound good
weird it's not really coming up in the
desktop audio
weird all right well no my audience oh
my some people in my audience disagrees
about whether they can hear it so that's
not super useful
all right well i think i think we're
probably fine so here's what i've been
trying to do
so i've been doing some some puzzles
okay
and i've been trying to play games
either
15 10 or 10 minute because the format of
pog champs i believe is going to be 10
minute plus 5 second which i don't
actually think is a format
for normal games on chess.com unless i
do like a custom
thing yeah so i've just been doing 10
minutes understanding that that's a
little faster than
than the ten plus five would be and
trying to do
so working on our vienna opening
variations that you and i went over and
then as black eric rosen went over
now we had a big we had a big
confrontation
about you saying do not play the
sicilian defense
under 2000. yes and eric saying well
what about the sicilian dragon
yeah and i've been giving that a couple
of shots and it's i it hasn't been
particularly terrible
you so you like it you like the
structure you've been getting it's not
bad i mean it's not it's
i've actually won a few games yeah okay
got it um well what we can do
is i i think it's like you you
you want to try to obviously build on
everything that you've already like
learned and practice yes
uh and at the same time uh you also want
to just kind of train certain concepts
pick up certain concepts
uh in something that you might
not have thought about right so i'm i'm
first of all before we even get started
uh
do you have any questions for me like
before we jump into analysis or anything
like that
nothing specific i mean definitely you
know you could pick random games
and we could look at something but i'm
i'm definitely having situations where
i'm trying to stick with my plan and get
the structure that i'm
going for and then my opponent will will
vary by one or two moves that i don't
recognize and then i'll end up in
something bad
you know and so it seems like that's
still a risk where
especially if we get closer and and
other coaches
are checking out what we're going over
and training
their students in exactly how to play
against me
i could very easily end up in a very bad
situation after move five or six
that yeah that's fair uh the the good
thing is that
and i think eric brought this up in your
lesson was the fact that
if you play an opening that's very uh
like to the point
very kind of theoretical and it has an
aggressive plan
they can prepare for that they might
surprise you with something and so if
you play something that's a bit more
like the dragon
or king you know king's indian setups
it's hard to prepare because it's
it's the same i mean you can't really
crack it early
um so let's let's start out with
an analysis board and i will invite you
okay
so are you in life chess yes i am okay
cool
so you should get this okay got it yep
i'm there
all right so i have i mean there there's
a
a handful of games here um
and maybe you know when when we look at
this
any time you analyze a chess game
you you need to kind of go through the
how do you analyze your chess games let
me ask you that first like do
how in depth do you analyze your chess
games after you play them well
so if there's a particular move where
i'm wondering
what the right where i kind of
determined it was a big turning point in
the game
i'll i'll usually go right back to that
first okay then i'll go and look at
blunders
and then i'll kind of take an overview
and see like especially if i fell behind
like what was the series of moves
where i fell further and further behind
okay
got it uh that's yes that's that's
actually like a i mean that's a very
good way of doing it
uh the the first check is always kind of
like where in the opening was i
surprised
right uh how did my opening go did i
play the move order correctly
uh and and that can be everything from
okay did they play something bad and i
didn't optimize my position
uh to you know something like
did i just forget the move uh did i
forget the plan have i have i had this
before so
uh like let's let's look at this game in
particular your opponent
in this game okay so you you were about
you're a thousand twenty seven your
opponent's thousand fifty six uh also
fun things to look at are like you know
some of their statistics
so for example uh the person that you've
played
has wow in in this game that we're gonna
look at your opponent has 17
000 games played that is a lot of games
so some experience there potentially
now if i play this is i have no i'm not
even sure who this was against
necessarily because i'm just seeing it
you put the moves together if i play 17
000 games
yeah and i don't improve at least a
little bit from where i am now i may
bail on chess i'm going to be totally
totally upfront with you i may be i may
have moved on to uh checkers by then
yeah so see i i said this in a in a in a
video that i did
i said i said uh
if you've played that many games then
yes checkers could be could be a way out
and people were like
what that's not nice of you to say i'm
just trying to save you some time so
or connect four yes um so
d4 uh knight f6 you you you have uh the
black pieces in this game so have you
flipped it to your
oh no okay let me flip that now i'm
looking at this from white's perspective
i'm looking at it from the standpoint of
white as i would say
okay but now i'm now i'm good okay so
c4 g6 knight c3
so far so good okay so this guy this
person's actually playing like
actual classical king's indian defense
yep uh
quite literally like knight f3 bishop e2
this is all the main line
now you don't need to really familiarize
yourself with main line that's not
something that
uh really comes into effect just yet
knight c6 played
castles and now you played 97 okay so
this knight d7 idea
yep good idea but talk to me about
why you're doing this uh to then play f5
okay yes and no it's actually usually
first to play e5
ah okay okay so this move
i'm going to give you an example let's
say bishop b3
this movement when you play knight d7
two pieces look at this square yes
so the first thing a king's indian
player does is make the person with the
white pieces
decide what's going on right here
uh why because f5 is a little bit too
weakening
so f5 with no e5 very dangerous and
actually
this game is a very good example of why
um
when you push this pawn what it becomes
weaker in your position
uh what becomes weaker i guess uh
f6 and f7 so f7 yes
f6 the thing is the way you can think
about this is when this pawn was here it
used to cover
that square right yes oops sorry that
would be
that's what we want to do f5 stops
guarding this
and the light squares in particular so
how can white immediately try to hop in
here
uh in there i guess uh e5
not really that doesn't even really help
oh bishop to
bishop to g5 okay well bishop to g5
pins this it doesn't let you play the e5
move but i'm talking about this square
in particular
what i want a piece for white oh
d5 is good but even better and see
it's it's not so natural it's this move
okay
and this move looks kind of barbaric
because it's like how do we
like so but do you see the power of this
knight
uh yes well because it's a fork of my uh
queen bishop and rook
yes queen bishop brooke not to mention
the fact like
worst case scenario look what's gonna
happen i'm not even going to take your
rook
i'm going to now go here and
uh yeah the house collapses wow so
this little outflanking maneuver knight
g5 it
you got to be very careful with the it's
the only weak square in your position by
the way
in this entire rectangle yep like it's
it's it's the one square where
everything can collapse
and so e5 before my f5 strategy of
moving the knight to d7
would have prevented all of this well so
so yes we're about to
we're about to kind of kind of move
along into this territory so for example
let's say i played d5
yep do you know where it's best to put
this knight
so i would i would look at
b4 and e7
um and my instinct would probably be to
go to e7
you're absolutely right the way the
king's indian works is it's very much
like a slingshot
uh you go back to go forward so
you are going to now prepare the move f5
however
here's the here's the small thing like
what if i play b4
yep again do you see the problem with
rushing with f5 right now
um
no not really i'm gonna do the same
thing okay oh say it's the same problem
okay yes i'm just gonna
i'm gonna hop right on into e6 uh and
like a you know a good player will will
kind of punish this setup so
yeah disallow my knight access to that
square
um h6 yes yes
very good h6 and f5 go together and okay
then you get
your center well i should actually no
incorrect your flank pawns rolling at
the enemy king
so uh traditionally speaking king's
indian attacks
look like this with with the closed
center
closed center and then f5
g5 f4 g4 etc you'll you'll bring these
pieces as well so
the knights will come out this way and
so on and so forth
um one determining
factor of whether or not this is even
possible
comes back to this move what if white
takes
okay so if white takes i think that
there's actually some
uh there's some some tactics here i
think if i recall correctly
uh hold on a second so if i take
i'm actually not so sure do i take with
the knight
from d7 it's it's it's actually i think
any
any move except the bishop move okay
because yeah because you don't want to
trade like this
yep um and just conceptually so you
understand that it's because of
all this right like you wouldn't you
shouldn't trade the piece that's
camping amongst the light squared pawns
right so you know
just for anybody confused why exactly
that that that is the way it is
um well there's your answer uh so
knight takes e5 with the d knight is
good because you did rotate it back
but this kind of position
with the
center more open f5
is not as good ah so this e5
f5 thing closed center that's what you
need
can you think about like why like why
why do you need a closed center to be
able to attack
uh is it just to interfere more with
white's pieces as i build my attack
yes it's basically the fact that you're
cutting off
easy passage for for the defensive side
like
the more space that is kind of locked up
the more the person has to go backwards
whereas
for example if you know you just go
crazy and play f5
the whole d file is open like white can
just jump in
and it's not clear who's attacking who
you think now hold on
if we back up just momentarily because i
want to go to the sort of key
so at one point the question was
assuming my e pawn is taken by white
yes how do i respond if white doesn't
take it and plays d5 that's a different
scenario but if white takes the pawn on
e5 then is the idea i want to take with
my
c6 knight no i i like what you said i i
think the oh okay
okay got it yeah this little rotation is
good
and you say well levy what are the plans
here um it's it's it's going to be a
longer game
um f5 is no longer going to be used as a
crazy barbaric attack it's more going to
be used to you know get your light
squared bishop in the game for example
um it's going to be maybe you bring your
rook to the center with pressure in the
future
this trade not bad um if this knight
takes like this you have you have
choices you can recapture with the
knight
yep you can take with the pawn the only
reason i don't like this
is it blocks the bishop hmm
right you're bishop and in my in my view
i wouldn't also want to even open up
myself to a queen trade at this point
because i'm thinking of bringing the
queen out you know maybe to the g
file to build some attack if it's
possible at some point
yeah exactly i mean if the opponent
wants they trade
uh let me ask you a question what's the
only thing in your position that's not
guarded
um let's see what is the only thing not
guarded now
uh oh that well no hold on uh
isn't everything guarded now well this
is why we this is why i ask
it's good to train this sort of vision
c7 the c7 pawn c7 ah
c7 yeah and so when you when you
identify that by the way this will this
will come
just naturally like it you'll just kind
of
the brain will automatically start
picking up on the fact like okay this is
unguarded
you say it doesn't matter he's too far
from it how will white attack this pawn
um how will white attack that pawn maybe
with uh
knight to b6 b5 rather
yeah either of these moves uh if i'm
gonna be annoying
probably d5 is a little bit better and
now the only way to guard this is to
play rook up
right blocking in my uh bishop
yeah so your position is just very
unpleasant if you kind of play like this
so
you bring up a very good point you want
to keep the game going don't trade the
queens
take with the knight and then and then
and so on and so forth now
in this game we played f5 so so there we
go now we learned something about the
opening
we know that e5 is actually a move of
preference i'm also going to give you
one more wrinkle
get all this i actually like to develop
the bishop
first here's why
because if they attack i'm happy making
this trade
ah so even though in our first lesson
you said
i should prioritize keeping my bishops
yes
uh rather than taking a night in this
once we're at this point
we would be dealing with a different
situation yes so
it's it's general rules and then you
start kind of adding the uh you know the
extra components so so the component
here is
you shouldn't trade the bishop for the
night unless there's a good reason
here's the good reason or i'll try to
convince you if it's a good reason
so now develop the knight to c6 yep so
you
you go ahead you can play it okay just
so kind of you have the
let's say a castle now now your plan
here is is is the same
you're playing with knight d7 so go
ahead and put that oh now i do
okay yep and you see the difference is
that now
that bishop trade for the night there's
no more central guard
right so you actually are just straight
up threatening to win that pawn
and the difference is is this bishop
really leaving a strong impression not
now
no no it's not uh and
by the way think about it like this
uh imagine both bishops are worth like
10 points
on on on the on the color of the square
that they control right like a a light
squared bishop controls ten points of
light squares and zero
obviously it doesn't see the dark
squares so
when you but the knights are 50 50 right
i mean think about it right because they
can they can hop around
if that makes sense yeah
now in this position
if d5 happens yep
then i guess i can completely undevelop
to b8
i can play b knight to b4
or over to e5
actually this is another benefit of this
bishop having taken the knight on f3
it's the fact that you can just go
straight into the center
right so knight d4 and then if i attack
you
you can support this with that same e5
move
right and you're not you're not really
worried about
for example on poisson right well now
the question is
you you know you remember you can
bring this back because uh the problem
here is this loses
a piece yep right so
there's all these tricks um but it's
good to get the opening going the right
way it's very good you did ask me about
this about this d5 because it always is
a little scary you know with white
having such a
such a um giant pawn center
yeah i like to play like this the world
champion magnus carlsen has played 97
set up so
um this is actually quite nice
okay uh any questions before we kind of
move on into the game itself
nope not so far okay perfect f5
takes takes okay i like gf5 queen b3
all right yeah so i've had this
situation a lot where
well actually no i've had it more where
the b pawn is not defended by the bishop
and in those cases i'll usually end up
putting my knight
on a5 to both attack the queen and
defend the pawn
okay that's not actually this situation
that's a situation i would like to maybe
talk about at some point but it's not
actually the situation here
sure i'm actually i'm gonna try to give
you a steadfast rule here it's
pretty rare in the king's indian but the
knight in the king's indian almost
almost never goes to a5 okay except
unless
here's the only situation the only
situation if
let's say the center looks like this i'm
just going to make a couple moves here
to transform the center
this is the only situation where a
knight on a5 makes sense do you see
why i put this pawn here uh to
block the path of the bishop block the
path of somebody else attacking your
knight the bishop yes
but uh the b-pawn white's b-pun yes
exactly
exactly um and and even then white can
still in this position try to play
things like a3 and b4
and right um you've got to really have
good pressure on c4
that is the only reason that you should
you should jump out here okay um
unless of course it you know traps the
queen or something so that's obviously
a separate situation okay so your
opponent goes queen b3 now
the middle game the chess middle game
yep
the best general advice i can give you
is always you know still scanning for
attacking moves captures
uh the interaction of your pieces and
their pieces
what does that mean so
well one thing i was thinking about here
and it
was i was worried about a uh discovered
check
with the move of the c-pawn yeah so i
think that was very much in my head for
like the next
many moves yes you you went i think you
played knight a5 immediately to get the
knight away yes um
am i hold on a second did i
skip a move bishop e3
okay 8f5 let me just back up right here
i in this position your opponent did he
didn't play bishop a3 he played
he played a3 not not that it's a giant
difference
but let me just be precise so it was
a3 now f5 takes takes
and then queen queen b3 okay right so
just a small
a small difference um you're right that
this is coming now the way you evaluate
this is
is this scary so
just thinking about it check what are
you going to play
well i guess either king to h8 or rook
to f7
okay or or maybe um
yeah i mean i guess that's you know i
the pawn to e6 wouldn't make sense
because
the yeah yeah the queen the queen is on
that diagonal so again i'm going to give
you one more step uh steadfast rule for
for king's indian positions um because
your
middle game with black will flow from
the ideas
that you kind of stock up on on the
opening
uh so rook f7 almost never good
okay but why well then the rook is
pinned and then i still might end up
having to move the knight the king if i
want to move the rook later
yes not to mention like for example just
a a very clear refutation uh you you
remember our night maneuver for white
yes
yeah here i think it just it's just
devastating i mean knight g5 is killer
and
you just yeah you can't not to mention
this move
so definitely between the two options
king h8 is the move
okay but uh there is still this
uh there's still this annoying thing yes
and so you your biggest nightmare is
losing on the light squares like this
definitely definitely a situation that
we want to avoid
which goes all the way back to the move
f5 that's why this is so dangerous
if you don't play it in the right way
the light squares on this diagonal
so you evaluated this correctly
and you played knight a5 now you played
knight a5 but he goes queen a2 the
the problem is that it's still a pr it's
still a threat right
yep it's still a threat um
and so you played e5 i actually like
this move a lot
i like it uh craziness might happen
so e5
he goes b4 and you just
man you you really want to fight you
don't want to go back you you
equal danger it up yeah i guess my
thought was
i want to try to disrupt white's plan
as much as possible and if there's a way
that the material could be equal but
might just
interfere with white's plan rather than
just getting my piece out of the way
i thought let me just try it because i
was already feeling like this was
already
pretty bad it's it's it's not
necessarily bad like like again bad is
is more you know you're down material or
you're
very obviously getting mated yeah um on
your uncertainty about a position just
means it's complicated it doesn't
necessarily mean that
so i like it like i i i like e4 i think
it's a good move
um again his best move is knight g5
because
and again just so we understand the
dynamics here
he wants this and this is a threat and
you can't defend against both
right you would be losing some material
here but he plays knight d2
and okay so this
i should have been able to to capitalize
or improve here
based on white not playing anywhere
close to the best move
right so you immediately noticed and
this is a good lesson for
for everybody is uh you immediately
notice that
this pawn is no longer guarded and if
you were to take and he were to take
and you were to take that'd be good
right
and that is absolutely correct um if you
plug this in retroactively to the engine
it'll tell you
actually david it's better for you to go
here
not allow this and try to take with the
knight that's what it will tell you
okay but that's a little bit [ __ ]
like in terms of like the the level of
the players and everything bishop the
way you're playing is is fantastic this
is why you don't
always need to trust computer i mean
knight c6 is a
it's a very nuanced move um and i'll try
to explain in a second why exactly
uh so actually maybe i'll explain right
away because it seems as though
pandemonium
occurs uh so here's the thing
here's the thing uh the engine likes
this
for it it likes knight c6 first because
it doesn't like you opening this
diagonal
that's what happens when you take with
the bishop the engine is is looking at
this and going when this night moves
this bishop will get traded and you see
all this all these weaknesses
right that's that's going to be an issue
but
yes human beings don't see that like
we just see we're up upon and we're
doing okay
and that's why i i commend that the way
that you played this
until you block with the rook so we
don't want to do that yes rook f7 we
want to just go to the corner
uh i think it's very dangerous for you
once you block and i think that might
have been
where things got dicey
yes to say the least wait no
hold on you're still doing great you
found knight c5 that's a fantastic move
oh did i okay yeah i mean i remember
this game but certainly not uh
i'm i'm re reliving it right now right
so i mean
you know some folks would get tunnel
vision here you know you just played
bishop here and bishop here
so they would be thinking oh okay i
might as well make a third bishop move
bishop a5 is horrible uh it's it's a
horrible move
can you tell me why white to move and
win here
um it's nothing to do with the bishop it
just has to do with the rest of the
position
maybe white bishop to c4 yes bishop c4
bishop h5 the point is that you you
remove your bishop from the game
is what you're doing and you're not
taking care of of yourself
that's right now i don't know which of
these two moves is better i think bishop
c4 very straightforward
and let me just also show you another
little tactical thing
i can defend this by playing something
like
queen f6 or queen e7 i don't know queen
let's say i play queen
f8 does white have to take this
um no no
it's actually a rare situation where you
have pressure
and i cannot stomp your pin there's
nothing i can do about it for one whole
turn
right so white can do anything i mean
white can
even play a move like this just bring
the rook and
there's a new piece joining the attack
yep so this is an important thing like
you don't need to cash out immediately
sometimes you do
sometimes you have to but not all the
time um and i commend you for the move
knight c5 and let me just
i don't know maybe you remember your
thought process why was why is taking
this way the right way
um well it just seems like my knight is
more active there
and maybe could help soon rather than
taking with the pond
you're absolutely right and you also
open up the bishop if you get one more
move
you're gonna go here right and then
everything is set
you're all good interesting but your
opponent's a bastard
to replace bishops before right um
now did i then bring my bishop out
yes and we will learn here uh about
okay so bishop e6 is incorrect it's
better for you to lose the rook for the
bishop
why uh because then i could
be in a position where the queen is
can't attack or can't be used or i'm not
sure
does it relate to the queen first of all
yes i mean
let's just bring let's just bring this
up um this is great for you you lose a
rook but you get
um a bishop for it right uh and not to
mention the fact that you have
basically three extra pawns it's two but
like i don't count this as a
as two bonds so
it's also just a matter of okay you
might say well i'm going to lose my rook
it's better if i go here and lose just a
piece
right i think this may have been my
exact thought process yes
um however this is not good
it is better to get a piece for the rook
than a full piece for nothing
so if you could get a rook for a bishop
you'll often realize that rooks are end
game pieces like do you really feel the
presence of this rook on the board
no no not yet you feel the presence of
this rook because there is a very
clear weakness but yeah if you just play
b6
for example that rook's not going
anywhere either
um so that's another lesson if you're
about to lose a rook
try to get a bishop for it um but
wait am i reading this right what
happened was takes takes and he didn't
even take the night
you tell me he played rook takes b7 oh
no
and he thought oh you know why he do you
know why he played rook takes b7
he spent three seconds on that move
you can't can't do that you can't just
you know i mean
all right so what did i do geez
well it could have been a matter of time
trouble that's the thing i don't i don't
know i i have um
you know we're on move uh what is it
19 and this game was 42 moves long and
white won so something had to go wrong
um let's just quickly look at this
position and then create
a it's hard to think about these things
live during the game so i want to kind
of try to make this your instinct
let's say you see in the game that queen
takes knight as possible and you're like
ah crap my position is going to be bad
but all of a sudden this happens yep
so if let me tell you if i'm playing
this position now after rook b7 i go oh
he missed a chance great
i'm better by how much by how much is
black better a little bit
is black almost winning what do you
think uh it seems
very marginally better okay very
marginally better now now talk about why
you think that is
um i mean i guess i have
better better pawn structure and
position
and i still have this this rook is still
pinned in a sense although right now
it's being blocked by
the knight i have an opportunity maybe
to get the king out of the way although
i don't
think i did it actually um
i could maybe try to force a trade on b8
and then continue sort of like
a position that maybe could have been
bad i'm still ahead by a pawn i guess
and i'm i'm
sort of getting a little closer to the
end game without having fallen further
behind i don't know
everything that you described is
completely correct uh
it's just sometimes like the the
sentences approach to the game like it's
it's completely accurate the problem is
that at the end of that we we have to
come up with a plan like we can
we don't just get bonus points for uh
you know uh
a slightly better position or a winning
position yeah so
uh the method now i'm actually curious
what i did because looking at it now
i'm wondering if i just tried to defend
the knight or or did i take the pawn on
a5 i have no recollection of what i did
yeah well we got to be careful because
this is still a threat yeah
so you move the knight to f4 you you you
hopped on in with the knight
um let me think here so whenever you
have something under attack
there are three options uh
defend it i mean right queen d7 yeah
queen e7 queen
f6 queen c8 uh sorry not not that this
which hits the rokin also um you can
block the attack
so actually in this position you you
have a very sneaky move d5
right which expands your center this is
guarded
and if i would get two moves here
i would probably just bring my queen and
maybe just bring this rook into the game
or something
maybe maybe that's something that i
would do or
use the open g file against your
opponent
slide the king over as you said but all
of a sudden
it's not clear again like who this is
worse for right yeah
so openh openg file it's a lot of
information this is this is the good
thing about like really dissecting a
game not just with the you know
analysis uh feature um
and another way would be just to create
a stronger threat on your opponent like
for example okay well
he has this but i'm gonna go here but
that's terrible because your bishop is
way better than that piece
right so you played knight f4 okay
and i think what i was thinking was the
idea of maybe a fork on e2
although right now if i ended up taking
the bishop
i would just lose the the knight but i
think that's what was in my head that
maybe that would be good at some point
yeah you can so that that that gets a
stamp on it
uh of being you know the approach of uh
simplification
you can take the bishop then the bishop
is no longer
guarding the knight and then
but the problem is that yeah the queen
is still there now of course you can
just
trade all these guys just trade them all
off uh
but i would argue you have better pieces
right you have better pieces um someone
in my chat is asking is there anything
wrong with the move knight c5 no this is
also a perfectly reasonable move but we
can't i can't analyze five options a
move so yep
some things i have to gloss over so
knight f4 only thing is about this move
is that it's loose that's the only thing
it's not guarded by anything
yep and he finds a great move to his
credit he actually finds a fantastic
move
uh it's actually according to my notes
of the game this is the longest that he
spent in the entire game and he probably
played the best move knight c4
so what is this attack um
well there's uh i guess if the pawn
wasn't defending
there would be a fork on d6 actually
another wooden what am i talking about
no what is that attacking
um don't just think about the knight i
think there's other pieces
yeah i don't know what it what is it
attacking i mean is is the
i'm not sure oh it's potentially
it could be brought in to attack the
rook
and then the queen and the knight would
be pointed at the rook
okay so there's a lot of thought about
the night but here's here's a new skill
we're going to add to our to our arsenal
today
it has nothing to do with the night
itself oh okay
is this guy now open ah
yep discovered attack on the night yes
which is as you mentioned loose
yes and so it's it's easy to start you
know coming up with these ghosts like
okay knight d6 95
but don't forget it just do a quick scan
before you know
before you start picking this up very
naturally like you'll naturally see this
this is what you're gonna see
and this is what you're gonna see it'll
happen naturally but
for now your opponent goes knight c4
don't just look at the knight
just look at how everything might have
changed oh the bishop now sees my knight
i gotta be careful
um in the game
after knight c4
you played d5 wow
okay striking the knight this is
this is chaotic i like it i like it
um now at the very simple level
d5 is not as good as moving the knight
because
he will just take take and then he can
recapture that's the
lead right um so he's won a pawn and
do you notice what else is a problem for
you here
the bishop is now under attack yes and
also this looks very scary
yep because he's got this now
right and you're you're with you can
still
probably defend the position but it's
very it's very
i mean it's it's a scary position
uh so that that one night move but
again like d5 how can you think about
this more generally
if you miss bishop f4 and you just play
d5 okay it's a little lucky right you
get you get away with it
just a little bit lucky but if you
see bishop f4 and you're like well i
played d5 i'm just going to counter
attack him it's bad because
you lose a pawn and you activate his
queen
yeah i'm and then the queen is forking
the rook and the bishop the rook the
bishop the c7 pawn it's
it's a little bit so it's better to just
move this guy somewhere safe yeah
even here like just just to be safe just
to be safe so was this
the point at which it started to become
more like a new level of trouble where
it were recovering was
seeming less likely well he didn't
actually take the knight
he played rook b3 which is a
fascinatingly curious move so
your knight is still hanging yeah your
bishop is hanging
his knight is hanging now let's see
something you spent
ah oh wow wow wow craziness
i saw this this brought up in my chat
they said is queen g5 a good move
so queen g5 just straight up threatens
me
right oh no guys 92 is bad don't forget
the queen
so no be careful um so i like queen g5 i
like it from the perspective of you're
seeing how your pieces are interacting
i like he finally finds this move
you take he takes
you take he takes yes
okay we're in an end game now
this is no longer the middle game this
is what's called a heavy piece end game
queens and rooks
so we've we've made it out of the middle
game both players had
had their spots where you know they
could have played slightly better but
that that's chess like that that is
literally chess and if the engine
afterward is like
this move is bad this move is bad this
move is bad that's where it gets hard as
a chess player because you're like oh my
god i'm playing so poorly yeah compared
to like
a cyborg you know right
now in at this point
who's who's winning as
far as you are concerned it is equal
okay actually
i would i mean it seems like my pawns
are a little better yes as i was gonna
say as
as far as you should be concerned you
are maybe a touch better yep
you're not according to again the
computer but that's practically it's
about
practical and engine evaluation i would
say that black here is a little bit
better as you said because of the
activity
the only drawback being this now i'll
tell you what my game plan here would be
david it would be this i would just go
for it just go for it
just go for it um and maybe try to break
obviously you can't play that right now
don't lose the queen
yep so and i don't care if it says plus
point six
at the 1100 1200 level this is probably
better
for black now let's see what happens and
also let's take into account the time
situation so at this point
you have five minutes and he has eight
right so time
management is is huge i mean it's it's
it's a
underrated thing to think about you if
you see yourself getting into time
trouble a lot
you have to just set a thing for
yourself i will not spend more than 15
seconds
on more than five moves in a game right
and and the thing i think at this point
with five and eight was
i'm also evaluating
given my familiarity with these types of
positions
i don't imagine the time trouble is i
don't imagine i'm going to run out of
time let me put it that way i think in
this situation the game ends before i
run out of time if i have five minutes
at this point
even if my opponent has eight got it
you're not wrong uh it and it's good
that you're not panicking when you get
five minutes
uh because some people you know some
people they see that low time they see
the the drifting from the opponent
and they start going oh it doesn't
matter you know how are they playing so
fast and they're still doing well
so what we're gonna analyze is only your
play
i will analyze the time management
element like for example on the next
move you spent 16 seconds
so in in five seconds give me five moves
for black
literally uh queen to g5
king to h8 rook to b8
um queen to e5
uh c6 although i don't think it's really
good yeah we don't want a6
a6 yeah it's good we need to we need to
get this work in the game hundred
percent
yeah like 100 percent um so rugby 8 rook
d8 rookie 8 rook f8
uh and yeah and i mean everything else
queen e5 kha now that you know this plan
all good
so we just got to be quicker if you
don't see the difference between a move
and another move and
none of them blunders anything crazy
like
sometimes we just gotta just gotta play
something and what did i play
you i like the move you played rook of
eight like oh i did oh okay
good good move the thing is it it it
like
it doesn't it doesn't make a mistake but
it doesn't do anything at the same time
it it brings the rooks to the game but
here's what i would have done like i
said i would play king h8 rook g8 that's
what i would have done because then
you can make the argument my rook is
attacking down the g file yeah however
just because the move doesn't do
anything doesn't mean it's a bad move
you just don't need to spend a lot of
time on it sure so
rook f8 blitz it out let him let him
think so
rook f8 nice rook fc one
okay now you played king h8 i like this
it came it took you some time to come up
with this
on the next four moves this this and
your next two moves
you spend a minute which is a lot of
time that's a lot of time in
especially when you're five so uh king
h8
he gives you check you come back i i
would like i said i would i would try to
maybe go for this but it's hard because
you know he he does something very
logical he he brings his uh
his rooks on the c file yeah and tries
to attack attack you here so king back
queen b3 okay now we make a mistake
yes but did it i think it might have had
an idea did you play c5 on purpose
yes i think my idea was what was my idea
my idea i think
was that if he took on yeah that that
was exactly the idea yes
that if he took then i attacked the
queen with rook to b8 and then it's
defended with the
with my queen yeah right okay
so c5 and rook b8 that it's actually
it's a
very nice idea i mean the to find the
coordination here
and attack his queen but in the end game
we want to try to hang on to our
material
even even if it's just a point you're
like all right so what like this he's
got double pawns like this counts as one
pawn yes
but when we do this we allow the rook
certain access into the position
it's just certain access like supported
by by this guy
again you've got these pawns so maybe
try try to use them somehow like try to
push forward like
slide the queen back maybe to e5 for
example
um f4 f3 now at this very moment
this is a problem yep he will go here
you cannot take right so
um that that that is a small problem but
he took rook v8 i don't think you lost
this game because you lost the pawn
or maybe he was just so good at the end
game that that's what happened
oh wow he played rook c8 check
wow he found that i was really hoping he
wouldn't
right i did not even see that when i was
developing this plan of attacking the
queen
so here's the problem here's the problem
it's that
your king is too weak yep and he can
hunt it down
queen c3 check
and if you block he will put some
pressure on this how will he do that
um
pressure on that oh rook to c6 because
my rook's pinned
yeah your rook is pinned and it is just
it's just unpleasant like you can defend
but here's the problem you will never
get to move again
yeah no one can move and he will bring
his king
and it's a king in pawn end game which
is i mean that's a separate
set of skills entirely so we'll we can't
do a tremendous i don't want to you know
sort of 10 000 different bits of
information but but so the real
miscalculation was my idea of attacking
the queen
i just missed this move yes had i seen
this i would have just
thought of something different yeah and
i think maybe focusing on this side of
the board but you know this is
that's the thing about end games i mean
end games um
still if there's an open line of attack
toward the enemy king
try to try to take it if you have a
two-on-one kind of situation with these
pawns
pushing them forward is actually very
dangerous like
for instance uh let's say in this
position
you know rook c1 even all the way back
here let's say we go we go with like
putting the rook more toward the center
of the board right let's say he does the
same plan
he goes for this black to move and win
blacks to move and make an unstoppable
threat uh
let's see here
i'm guessing it has something to do with
the back rank
well let's do our uh let's do our
process checks captures attacks
so i mean the i have two checks
available i guess which would be
uh rook to d1
or uh queen to c1
rook d1 and queen c1 and i think you can
rule them out both pretty quickly yes
yeah okay no but
but that's the thing like it's it's in
another position one of those moves is
going to win the game
so now would i would i want to be
looking at rook
f to d7 here well see that's a that's a
little bit of
tunnel vision because you you want to go
down here but that's it's not forcing
that's not a forcing move
right in fact that move is
it has a tactical drawback remember why
this rook is here
because it's it was pinned for a while
it's shielding your king from his queen
yeah and if you move it
i could lose the queen if rook takes on
e4 right yeah but then you would be a
genius because
watch then you would get your back rank
and then i would
oh yeah yeah then i would build you a
statue is what i would do
so um it doesn't actually lose the queen
but it's
you know i want to instill things that
nine out of ten times are going to
be so should i have moved the king at
that point
uh right here here yeah no no i said you
have a win
so you only got through checks right and
you stopped here don't stop at looking
at that
captures and attacks so what does that
mean we gotta look at the captures
you've got
yep all bad i think
you think right okay so queen queen
sacrifice is not going to
not gonna cut it yeah what does attack
mean
um well i could attack the queen on d2
with the rook ah with the rook
right oh were you gonna stay with the
queen well yeah i mean i was i guess
that was the first thing i was thinking
of but yeah i didn't i didn't get to
attack with the rook quite yet
but that's more logical queen d2 would
be the super grand master move just
trade the queens and make a draw
um but super grand masters are boring
and we want to win pog champs too so
uh rook d2 yes rook d2
attacks not just the queen what else is
under attack
um the f pawn and you win
checkmate right check and mate
wow and as i said something about super
grand masters uh hikaru himself popped
up
hi hikaru uh maybe okay i don't think
hikaru would have played queen d2
uh but there's other super grand masters
that i wouldn't have uh that i won't
name
holy [ __ ] what no i mean i just i
this entire area i thought i was just
dead after i mean my last stand
was pawn to c5 no man see that's the
thing
yeah you think you're losing but why do
you like it's an emotion more than
anything you don't actually have an
objective reason
why uh you know why you're losing it
just
feels loose but oh it felt like it yeah
yeah
we need to get you just every game
thinking you're winning no matter what
and then
um but there was there was a lot of
different moments
to recap this game in particular uh we
start all the way back at the
at the opening let's get right here
so first big mistake that went wrong
was knight to d7 and then pushing f5
it was f5 it wasn't like d7 not not
right it could
if i had played e5 at this point it
would have been okay right it's e5
and then don't forget the other move h6
in the future before you go f5
right so e5 uh
h6 and then f5 together now the thing
that often happens in these situations
is
especially when i'm thinking like okay
i've got all these moves i want to play
and i need to play in order to get my
setup e5 and then h6 and then i'm
looking at f5
i just start taking attacks and
my i basically have to abandon my plan
or
i risk you know just getting in a
horrible position while i'm moving my
pawns around
okay sorry uh you what was the first
part of
of what because you said you're looking
at all these different things but yeah
in other words
i'll have a plan that i think is a good
plan like for example
i'm gonna play e5 and then i'm gonna
play h6 and then i'm gonna play f5
but in the in the span of trying to get
those three moves in
my opponent plays stuff that just makes
that impossible because i have to
respond to what my opponent is playing
and then i just get totally
discombobulated
okay so the the best way really the best
way to deal with it i mean technically
the best way to deal with it like the
way
any time i have students i'm like okay
here's an opening and i always say like
when you play a game when that happens
mark it down
just like put like a little star like
mental star write it on a notepad write
a piece of paper
so that if we meet or i mean you can
also dm me but i mean it would be it
would be easier you know with would
be more instructive for viewers as well
be like hey this specifically happened
so for example look
uh here's here's something that could
happen
right um your opponent plays instead of
a3 which is an exceptionally terrible
move
well it's not terrible but it doesn't do
anything um they play queen d2
this prevents you from playing what this
prevents me from playing
um
i don't know h6 yes no of cour you know
yeah you know
that's the problem is that you don't get
this right
well you already know what the problem
is with this move right
yep right it's it's knight g5 and then
the knight hops it
okay so then either you got to just say
all right screw it i'm just going to
play this position
or we have to avoid this kind of a
spot so for example maybe
uh we play h6 early on
we play h6 early on or we don't just
pre-move our plan
so one of the reasons that i told you
about this bishop g4 thing
is that it creates this trade situation
in the center
and your opponent has to guard the pawn
that's that's that's really the thing is
that they react to you
um so in this position remember go for
this bishop g4 thing if you have it
right so it's like a move order thing so
play bishop g4 and then let's let's try
to get accustomed to what that position
would look like
uh let's say i castle now again you
don't have to take
yeah because i didn't attack you
so you can continue with your
development so now i could play
uh either e5 or h6 if i want to do h6
first
yeah e5 h6 and by the way even knight d7
here is probably fine for the setup that
you're that you're looking for
okay yeah i guess i would play move the
knight back first at this right and
let's say i played but should be three
and i think oh
i don't want you know i don't want that
to happen so i can't but
also remember something else the knight
is why you have to play h6 right
yeah i can also take the knight yeah
literally that's that's actually the
whole reason
is why your life gets a lot simpler
without this night in my opinion this is
always how i teach it
uh with this little wrinkle where just
trade
and then go for everything with e5
with this whole setup e5 1975 is also
good
um because then you don't have to deal
with this stuff and
if you trade that bishop but your bishop
is not so useful anyway right so
so you you do it like this and you've
added an opening tool as far as the
middle game is concerned
uh do you remember like uh like like
certain elements for example
knight a5 almost never yes only if i
have a pawn on c5
yes and you probably the way you you
have it um
won't play it because you play knight c6
first right um
the way that the game proceeded uh was
a3 f5 takes takes
and i think we got knight a5 now e5
everything that you played up like here
was
i liked the way you played i mean you
you navigated the chaos pretty well
equal danger you know you use the
concept of equal danger
um knight g5 here we we said obviously
it's okay it's a good move for white so
maybe
just bring the knight back but you saw
this
now you know before the lesson maybe
maybe not quite
um and
there was you know other other small
things that you actually picked up on
very well like for example
let's not pin ourselves let's bring the
king to the corner right which i did
during the game and then realized it was
not a good idea
yeah exactly unfortunately sometimes in
chess uh
we have to make the mistake and then
learn and then yeah and then it sucks
you should see how many times after the
game i realized how i could have won
not super useful in that game
maybe for the next one that can be that
can definitely be frustrating
um but so conceptually the point of this
type of opening
is to get to the middle game without
having blundered anything or suffered a
major loss
so that i can start pushing the hg and f
pawns uh primarily the
the uh yes like but remember only when
the center is closed right
when the center closes so you have two
different kings indians i would say
the king's indian which is locked and
the king's indian which is a little bit
more open that one is a little bit more
uh mysterious okay
meaning it's it's it's a little bit
harder for me to give you like a
straight up game plan whereas
you know if i taught you like the
stonewall dutch
which if you want to learn or not is is
kind of straightforward it's like okay
this is how you set up your pieces every
game and this is this is your game plan
it's just you know it's not like you
have to figure it out on your own so
um okay i feel like we should also
analyze something with the white pieces
okay i feel like that would be
that would be helpful let's do it and
then maybe i don't know
how how how energetic are you feeling i
was thinking would we start
like 8 30 8 45 like two hours or 90
minutes
we can see how it go i mean we could
what are you thinking
however your energy is how oh no i mean
in terms of so you're thinking analyze
white and then maybe play a game
yeah okay okay sounds good
no no uh no laundry today is there no
laundry today i
may have an uh a grocery delivery though
if that happens
uh hopefully it doesn't happen at a
critical moment of a game but that
that should only be a brief distraction
oh yeah we uh
luckily i live i live close to a new
york city has the benefit of having some
24
7 uh like fruit fruits and vegetable
stores so oh those are the best yeah
maybe
maybe we should spar oh thanks for the
suggestion like physically no i'd rather
not embarrass myself but thank you
um so i don't know why
why chess fans are just obsessed with
with with physical confrontation it's
probably because we're all very bad at
it
oh so i should flip to white right
because i was white in this yes yes okay
oh yeah so here's me actually going for
my vienna opening
i i love it and he plays a good move he
plays an annoying move
um the idea here is to play d5
uh well i don't know if he knows that
yeah but
uh he didn't know that actually uh but
he should be playing d5 actually the
best move here for white when he doesn't
bring the second night out is the very
aggressive d4
uh okay so and if the pawn takes then
where does my knight go
oh i take with the queen oh yeah yeah
and there's no knight c6
yep which normally is a good move so now
you would
castle queenside got it and quick
development
um you played d3 uh he plays h6
f4 d6 knight f3 knight d7 right
everything is perfect so far
castle's b5 i saw there was a game you
you did play this again please don't
play b3 our bishop feels very bad if
i got i think i just got confused yeah
yeah so we want to we want to try to get
the bishop out this way
um okay okay i like a3 good prophylactic
move
a5 okay prophylaxis the name of the game
straight up by the way yeah i mean you
know your bishop always has a drop back
now so the same way we need to enter the
middle game from the king's indian we
need to now enter the middle game
from the vienna uh you played bishop e3
the only small drawback of this move is
what's it can get hit
this move can get hit it can get hit
with
um ah yes okay the same
pain in the ass night move by the way
yep with colors reversed
so prepare this move
disallow knight g4 oh okay h3
yes and then this and right and then and
then
here's the thing is this a closed or
open position
right now it's open right now it's
actually closed
is it okay good but but wait i wanna
hear why you said open
i wanna hear why well it seems like
there's still
i guess i'm not really sure it seems
like when there's this number of
possible pawn moves it feels open
okay that's actually an interesting aha
so you're looking at it from the
perspective of pawn moves
yeah interesting so the way i try to
simplify it down to there's eight pawns
per side it must be closed
oh if all the pawns are there it's
closed yes however
your what you just said there are a lot
of pawn moves
that allows the position to become more
open okay it allows it to become more
open but for now it is closed now
what does that mean pawn moves don't
open the position right this does not
open the position
no no pawn breaks
open the position so that's either a
trade or
offer of a trade so how how can we do
that in this position
um take the pawn on e5 first of all
there's this move
yep and also d4 right which could
potentially change the position a little
bit
yeah um yes
h3 is perfectly reasonable perfectly
solid now now you played bishop e3 here
here
bing boom okay straight fine
can't be oh f6 oh
that seems bad for black right i think
f6 is one of the worst moves i've ever
seen in my life because it's blocking in
this chain of bishop and queen
on the king's side on my king's side
it blocks that in but but that that
actually is like a second or third tier
uh in terms of like importance i think
more than
anything else you gotta think what does
that weaken why is that so bad
what does it weaken um the g6 square
the the g pawn um
all the light squares e6 yeah right yes
yes exactly just like in the king's
indian think about it from the
the weak squares so
[Music]
this this this this i mean if you could
teleport your queen that would literally
be made unfortunately right
can't tell for your queen so
when i see this my first
instinct is to play the move knight h4
because i want to hop my knight into g6
yep
i want to bring my queen to g3
uh i want to play queen g6 or queen g7
and knight h4
optically like just scanning this
position looks like it should win by
just by force it looks like it
there is no way for black to stop this
and this
right the computer is a scumbag and is
trying to argue with me that black
should now
justify the move f6 and play the move g5
but
no human being plays just like that so
um
you know and it's apparently trying to
tell me that this is somehow okay
because if i play queen f3 and threaten
mates
literally mate black is just in time to
play this
check and run away and take the knight
ah but
do humans play like this no
certainly i don't um no and so knight h4
is
usually something that that would just
that would just be crushing i mean
there's other suggestions here you know
f5 and so on
yeah in this position f5 is what i look
at and i remember we had a whole
conversation about
f5 versus taking e5 in different
situations
different situations if if you're
helping their development maybe not but
f5
always always a good option just to take
some space now i think you
you did play that and he played knight
c5 this is not a bad move
a great move fantastic understanding you
do not want to make that trade that's
what middle games are all about
yeah my thought was that i have this
open diagonal and
i want to keep that yeah i mean your
bishop is worth probably about four
points and his knight is worth two and a
half
um relative value as as the game is
progressing bishop b7 okay
remember this maneuver yes remember it
for
for good because you are going to
you are going to um come across stuff
like this
okay where there are you know certain
squared weaknesses and
uh you can take advantage of them
when you look at a chess board this same
knight move to the right
is the same knight a5 right as in the
king's indian
medium yes yes it's a knight going to
the right side of the board and being on
the edge but it's very different right
because
it i mean it's it's just very different
i mean the knight is going to hop in and
attack the rook and do some serious
damage here whereas in the king's indian
the knight has no way back into the
center
right and on g6 it's defended by the
pawn
the defender of the pawn and this rook
is just miserable it cannot go here it
cannot get here
it's uh it's very bad
so knight h4 now the other thing is
you're not gonna win this game unless
you trade some pawns
you just if i say you can never trade
pawns again
uh it won't work it just won't work like
how
how will you win if you can't trade
bonds where are you gonna go
um which is why this move is by the way
so powerful it actually doesn't even
rely on a punch rate so
uh
having that having wondering i'm
wondering what i did
so you played h3 which is which is fine
but it's not you know there's no oomph
to that movie yeah
so uh give me a move with some oomph is
h3 would h3 be considered
beta uh
chess is a pretty pc world i feel like i
can't say that yeah i don't like that
type of stuff i mean i just in my space
in the political space i'm called beta
regularly so i'm immune to it you know
oh yes yes as far as um um
yes yes for sure i i definitely know
what you're what you're saying i just
feel like i feel like in our
in our sphere of the world um that's a
yeah there are certain words i still
have to avoid unfortunately i like it i
appreciate that i think that's better
well i mean i would certainly look at
a4 and then recapturing with
knight to a4 and then looking at b6 as a
possible place for the knight to go
oh wait that would be crazy well no at
that point it would be protected by my
queen
okay yes but i do control this two times
right oh that's right yeah okay so
that's a terrible idea
no actually a4 is not it's not bad
because they can take this would
actually be nice the problem is this and
you have to go backwards
ah okay that's actually more of the
problem but that's a that's a that's a
you know again a4 is a nice idea what
about what do you think about b4 you
like this
um did i play this because i feel like i
went through the thought process of
exploring this i guess i was thinking so
b4
uh if the black pawn takes then if i
take back
i'm attacking the knight and my bishop's
defended by my rook and
my knight um so maybe it's okay
it's a great move it's um it forces his
knights to some uncomfortable squares
like
the ugly square of d7 back to where it
was um
the only thing that's a little tricky
about this move is a move like knight a6
and now you're gonna think oh i gotta
defend this pawn and
you're not wrong i mean you you probably
do have to defend that one
uh so but i just wanted to kind of draw
your attention to this but what about d4
d4 i mean i guess if the pawn takes i
would look at taking with the knight
because then e6 might be an interesting
square for the knight
not to mention when this knight moves
here who has a free path to the right
oh the queen could go to yeah g3 yeah
this would probably win by force i mean
if this trade were to happen
uh black should not take so central
trades
of the pawns when the king is on the
opposite side you will get this more
with white with kings indian you castle
early they castle early it's
you know you're not gonna you're not
really gonna get it but shredding open
the center is usually a good idea
so if the if the position gets kind of
like bogged down
where i'm not really sure if i can't
i've identified squares that might be
good attacking squares but i can't
really access them
and it looks like trading upon is sort
of like the next thing
i would be better off pushing for that
trade generally speaking in the center
than on the sides of the board
in the center if the enemy king is
actually on the other side
so by other side even just by one by one
file
oh you mean
you mean like if the king had been
castled then it would it's like close
but
yeah i mean i guess is is the d file
considered the other side when the king
of the king when the king is on the
e-file ah i get what you're saying well
yes
um because you're opening the center so
this is two central lines here
okay uh you can use the d file to then
get in
into e6 so yes uh
that that is a very fair question
because you know you're not actually
opening the e file you're opening
this side uh yes i kind of i kind of
skipped over that the other thing is you
you are opening
this entrance point sorry with this
queen transfer so that's
that's how intermediate level players
will begin to kind of add
at this skill like how do trades affect
other pieces
not just the piece that's moving
but okay i'm curious to see what
happened because
you played h3 he played b4 so see he's
fighting even though he has no
no effing business fighting you with his
one active knight garbage bishops
and king in the center yep so you played
92 best move
he played knight d7 again one of the
worst moves i've ever seen in my life
wow and did i did i lose this by the way
yes unfortunately okay um
but again you remember that maneuver
that you did not play
yes knight h4 yep because you've gotta
go this is what you gotta ask yourself
the king is in the middle of the board i
need to attack it with the queen how the
hell am i gonna do that without moving
the queen necessarily
like if i say yo you need to check
the king in three turns but you can't
move the queen right now
like you go here here here easy
but i say you can't move the queen right
now yeah
so you got to move the knight yep and
then yes
then it's just only two moves for the
check yeah yes
okay you played c3 i don't hate this
move i think this is a perfectly
reasonable move takes takes
d5 aha
tricky pawn move
what pieces open the bishop now is
unleashed
yes and you've got to see this now it's
it's not winning for him
actually it's actually not winning for
him it just looks a little unpleasant
yeah so you played this now when he
played bishop c5 did you
did you were you surprised by this were
you like oh crap i was surprised by it
but i definitely understood you know the
implications
yeah cause you just have this yep and
you know
but we want to not be surprised by stuff
like this we want to see those things
coming and and
predict that we're fine right we don't
need you know we we're okay
uh so you played d4 now by the way
you're winning because two things are
under attack
so this should be six his king is right
here so what should you do
oh my man took the pawn what a beast
great move great move even though you
don't have an immediate cash out
he took back and let's see
oh oh okay
no no you you didn't make a mistake but
as i said
uh the winning move here is quite
stylish um
okay so first things first you can't
take this because of one
i can't take that because then i lose my
queen very good you can't take this way
because
why would you do that he would just take
back right
so
huh how do i ask this question is there
a rook sacrifice on b6 that would make
sense just to get that knight out of the
way
well if he takes with the knight you're
brilliant but unfortunately oh he has
the queen
yes but if you face with the knight dude
i oh my god i might
this might be the the best student of
all time yes
the only problem is that remember your
bishop used to cover that square
yeah yeah he's got long he's got she
could get away
he could get away and then you can push
and you could say well my past pawn is
so strong
you're right but you're not mating him
anymore yeah
oh there's a move here that's just i'm
trying to it's a it's a real it's a
really creative move
uh it it takes advantage of this pin
of that pen yeah it's basically that
this pawn can't take that square
knight f4 oh okay
and what's the threat of the move of the
night coming here
um it then going to g6 or
anywhere anywhere okay anywhere yeah g6
h5 i mean it's
yeah like you said earlier in 96 if
castles
first of all there is a fork there is
also knight takes d5
and then what about the bishop on b7 oh
you've got backup
oh yeah there oh okay yeah your million
dollar bishop which you did not trade a
long time ago
uh i am not going to sit here and
pretend like the move knight f4 is
supposed to come naturally but
sometimes when there is a pin
moves that don't look possible are
possible yeah
and a move like knight f4 is uh is
really good yeah um
now in this position you played bishop
b3
he played bishop what what
oh you had a little bit of tunnel vision
this was your plan
right yes exactly yeah but his move
removed the guard of a piece
and now i'm blocking it oh wait no of
which piece
of the d-pawn yes instead of going here
you just you just grab this that's it
easy we win now because he can't castle
the rook is hanging
and we just shred open the center of the
board slowly
just don't lose a queen but did i do
that or did i not do that no that's what
i said i did television
before but this is still a very tricky
plan
okay white to move and win cash in on
your plan
um white's a move-in win so when i take
i take the knight
the queen takes back then i take the
bishop oh amazing
but you didn't play it in the game no
what happened
this was the i mean this was this was
this was freaking brilliant i mean you
just it looks like he can finally castle
yeah but no no no no no no no
no absolutely not his position is a lie
just like our coronavirus numbers okay
sorry so what if so what did i play
that's true by the way yeah
so you went
after castles g4 wait now you did it now
you did it yes
wait takes takes takes oh but he's
this inclusion
allows him to oh my god i hate chess
i hate chess i'm i'm so i'm i feel bad
so i think here then i was thinking
about
okay i have to move the queen but i also
need to defend i would love to just
take the pawn on d4 but
the knight on e e2 will be double
attacked when i do that
so what do i do and i think i ended up
going with queen to d2 maybe or did i
take the pawn no no i
think you oh you did yeah you did go
queen you two
you you do have to take because the
problem is that you're gonna lose the
night no matter what
right so
[Music]
you should just take the pawn anyway and
what did i do play this d2
yeah you you played queen d2 but the
thing is here's here's here's the way i
look at it
you spent 44 seconds on queen d2 yeah
when you take that much time in a 10
minute game you're unsure
yes and eight to nine times out of ten
you will play a bad move
oh so so then am i better off just
playing it quickly what's the strategy
no the strategy is that is that when
when you see this i i
for sure think that this is the first
thing that you think of yeah for sure
because you're like my queen's under
attack
two ways so why not just take the pawn
i'm gonna lose the night no matter what
whether regardless of where i go
but then we start analyzing
yeah what no queen takes d4 now let me
ask you a question if this happened
where do you have to move this rook
um well if i move it to e2
then i lose the knight and then if i
take the rook then i lose that rook also
so that doesn't seem so good
yeah you've got to make sure that the
knight has a guard right so so maybe f2
yeah you have to go to f2 yeah even if
you don't like it i don't care
you can't lose the knight that's that's
that's all it is so
um yeah i think it was uh and let me
just check the time
situation no it was yeah it was
it was relatively relatively balanced so
yeah queen d2 he played rookie two
whoa what happened here what was rook d6
well my thought was if i take the rook
then i lose the queen i didn't
immediately think of some other place to
put the queen so i figured i would
just trade queens and then i realized i
was attacking the queen with an
undefended rook
okay that was a mental mistake i mean
it's chess so i guess they're all mostly
mental but
yeah it's it's i guess the thought
process there is that potentially what
you scanned was
this and if he takes my queen i take his
queen
right so that's not actually getting the
queen out of danger on e2
anyway so it was just a disaster right
exactly i mean
it's more just like well what if he but
what if that doesn't happen that's the
question we have to ask what if that
doesn't happen brutal well yeah i mean
this is literally an example of chess is
a game of one blunder that guy played
like a
bad player for 25 moves he played one
good move and
uh he he stumbled into a winning
position with e takes d4 so
yeah uh you you played quite well but
now we know to punish a king in the
center
we got to try to shred open the position
and these little night hops
to try to bring knight in to a
devastating square knight h4 would be
would be quite bad
um huge loss in the battle of ideas as
my audience
is probably very familiar with the
phrase
yes and uh at the very end i
i was going to talk about rook takes a
six but um
okay just ju i will do it i will do it
fine okay
uh hikaru pointed it out i will show you
a cool idea here at the end
uh let's okay so you played
this i think this bishop b3 idea
here here here
here here here here here
okay wait a second right in this
position okay
this is why you should always look
for uh captures
remember this move knight f4 that i
showed you earlier
uh yes when there was a night there
before yes
yeah the yes the queen opposite the the
king so in chess there are certain
creative sacrifices
there's like just a separate category
certain creative little tactical
sequences
so when i say the queen you know when i
say like captures this is the only thing
right
because yeah i mean i could take the
rook but i'd then lose the queen yeah
yes but you have one more capture that
makes some sense i could just take the
bishop on a6
exactly and if i take back you take my
rook
that's that is there that is an option
yes
and so then if if i end up losing the
queen
then i take the rook with check and i'm
i'm better off than the alternative
correct and if something like king h7
you still can pick up this rook oh
that's right
yes now okay the the the truth of the
matter is
this does exist in this position but
i can't put a i can't put a learning uh
you know what i mean like i can't put a
a term on this kind of a thing like i
i can't be like well you should have
seen rook a6 you know
um but if you think about in any
position just scan the captures
like just just just scan them and see
the implications you you know that this
is guarded by this okay well why can't i
just take that
like what happens if i take that right
well if he takes me i take his rook if
he takes my queen
oh that's a check you know that's the
big difference is that if that was not a
check it would be
maybe a bad plan um and so yeah what
what what hikoro points out is it it is
it is a very very nice idea i mean rook
a6 and then
rook 8 and then knight d2 and the game
goes on and in fact
you actually have a two ropes and a
night i maybe stay in it
you maybe stay in it yeah the only the
only question is gonna be can black uh
do damage to you with the with the open
king
because you have an open king so can he
do this and can his pawns you know break
through so
rookie six now it's a it's an amazing
move uh it's it's very rare and i just
the only way we'll really find stuff
like that is uh just scanning the
captures just seeing the peace
interaction
um you up for a game before we call
tonight yeah okay why don't we do this
um now should i be doing 10 since 15
plus 10 is gonna be significantly longer
than what the tournament will be or are
we far enough away where i should be
doing
15 10. you you can play whatever you
feel comfortable in if you want to play
10
play 10 you know um
now if you if you're doing it to just do
it like just play
that's one thing if you want to
make like a training regimen as i told
you like the first time just play
like two three games a day yeah i've
been playing fewer games and playing
longer games that's been my uh my
strategy
so that's like that that's how you
should do it but
you know i said before you were playing
2-1 if you like 2-1 that's
you know it's not uh it's not the
tournament format but you're pretty far
away from yeah
yeah no i'm moving away from that well
no what i was even going to say is
you're you're far from the tournament
you want to play some 2-1 dude
it's not like you know it's not like you
have a drinking problem or something and
i'm telling you right
do it like by all means 2-1 is chess
should be fun for you i don't want to
make it a purgatory of of course
training method or whatever so
um i have a subscriber that wants to
play you in a 10 minute game what's your
what's your what's your username random
random zorro arc
and just remember that you could
challenge david to an unrated game
because i will be
talking through the ideas so
okay now let's patiently await
so am i waiting for a challenge or are
you setting this up yeah i'm i'm asking
my
my my guy to to tell me his username
hopefully this doesn't take any longer
than a minute because that would be
annoying uh
dude okay so by the way since you're in
new york where where are you
on is indoor dining even going on right
now oh dude i don't need that
come on no i don't go anywhere i don't i
don't outdoor dine indoor dining you're
not doing outdoor either okay
no no no no i did it once i when i moved
recently i took too much to uh two
friends out who helped me move to a
burger spot but
no i don't i'd rather i'd rather not i
mean it's crazy some of these crowds you
see build up
yeah was it a what was the burger spot i
used to love in brooklyn
was it uh it's right on atlantic it's it
was like 888 burger or something like
that
atlantic avenue in brooklyn yeah oh
that's i i worked around there
uh but actually
okay here uh let me write in your chat
the username
just so you know uh dude can you send uh
send uh david bachman the challenge it's
it's david pakman it's like
his name so david okay got it you got
the challenge
yep okay cool oh oh i didn't get the
challenge no i got the username
oh we've established what the username
is
okay send them a challenge go ahead and
uh yeah i know
yeah offered to start the game some
folks have to have the game starting
option chess.com did not
offer that to me because i'm too
immature they think that i would do some
crazy stuff
but i promise i won't guys now i
actually can't see who this
is because of how hold on a second let
me see ah there it is okay
oh perfect all right we're in we've got
the black pieces
um we're not going to snipe this guy's
1200 across all rating categories
um all right so i think i go with my uh
my king's indian here right
yes knight f6 so this is funny his
rating is exactly 1200 but he has played
games
that's suspicious to me
well listen i i think this guy's listen
i think if the subscriber wants to play
it's
it's it's all good um oh they say they
play unrated okay
um all right so i think here i still
proceed with my plan of bishop to f7 oh
to g7
yes do you know the opening that you're
getting hit with
um this is the indian game
so you're playing the indian setup you
could castle here obviously it's
completely fine
he is playing something called the
stonewall
so it's a dark squared opening when it's
when when white is playing it's a light
squared opening and it's sent when black
is playing it
uh it's a light squared opening that
that is not a good move because you can
continue in king's indian style
yeah so my i would probably play d6 here
and then look to bring the bishop out
okay sure sure i'll let you i'll let you
do it as you do it um
notice how because he put three pawns on
dark squares it means that his
light squares are weak right yes so
trading a light squared bishop and
playing d5 against this setup is
actually
usually the better way positionally but
if you're just the kings indian guy
through and through you got to play what
you know okay
uh how do we continue our development so
i would think about putting the bishop
on g4 here
sure just like we talked about yeah um
there's a small difference the way he's
playing it it's gonna be kind of hard to
implement our exact king's indian attack
yep since he's also pretty advanced all
right let's finish our development with
knight c6
okay all right so far so good now we're
gonna have to play the move e5
at some point maybe maybe next by the
way because we we actually can
so would i be looking for e5 trade pawns
then knight to d7
um let's think about this so you play
knight d7
because you are going to push your e and
f pawns
right if i lose the e pawn in a trade
maybe that
plan is less relevant yes okay
i i mean i know why he's doing that he
wants to move his dark square bishop
so you have knight d7 as an idea you
have the immediate e5
um which one do you like more
i kind of like moving the knight now
okay sure go knight t7
so 97 is good it supports e5 a lot your
dark squared bishop is strong
uh i'm basically letting you play moves
that you know you you feel as though are
are completely okay i don't wanna i
don't wanna push too much now you are
ready to finally
so now i would play e5 or would i want
to look at playing h6 first is a
question no i think i would play e5
yeah because h6 is only to stop what
the knight from coming to g5 right yeah
so you just you do your thing very nice
and at this point then i can't come to
g5
because then i take the queen exactly
i'm sorry two yeah g5 yeah yep i would
love it if that happens
this trade in the center is gonna be
great for you okay so
so i think i take back with the pond you
think correctly
okay um so now i think i go
to e7 with that knight
i think so too i think i think i think
e7 is fine yeah you got a5 e7 before b8
i think i mean i guess the other
possibility would be no it's a terrible
idea yeah okay
what was the other idea to put the
knight on e4
i'm sorry no i'm sorry to play e4 um
but then i just lose that pawn it's
undefended
yeah knight okay all right man he's uh
he's really
so now i would start thinking about f5
again
okay so you're thinking about f5 again
there is a there is one issue
and you've you i want you to find it
because you you've
you had a problem in another game on the
same diagonal
so if i go to if i go to f5
and the pawn takes and i take back
then what happens
well it's the diagonal that i'm talking
about uh when you play f5 who do you
open up
um oh the dia oh i see i could
there's a discovered check there if d6
and then i'm not in good shape
yes yep so maybe now i look at h6
with the idea to play
g5 maybe oh you want h6 g5 oh wow
i mean listen don't take my i don't know
what i'm doing i
i mean i mean i guess i would also be
looking at knight to um
knight to c5 would be a possibility okay
and also and and so the real problem
here with you playing f5
is his bishop on c4 right
right because he'll he'll discover it
attack you so there's a way to maybe
go after it that's another idea like
knight b6
uh but we don't want to fall too far too
far in the hole so if you want to play
h6 g5 like
let's play it so that we don't you know
we don't have any bonus time all right
i'll do although i think i i think i
probably could have come up with
something a bit better but we're let's
give it a shot
yeah no this is completely fine there is
one maneuver here which someone in my
chat pointed out he's like a 1900
uh rated player okay so you have no
choice you got it i think i take it
you yeah you gotta take it so the other
idea here which is what i thought you
were going for
with h6 sidestep the king away from the
diagonal
so just tuck it behind that h6 pawn
right and then go for f5 anyway
okay um yeah i mean i think i like the
idea of moving the king
maybe of of giving some space to the
queen by moving
the um knight on e7 somewhere although
there's really no obvious place right
now
um
so i think i'm going to move the king
yeah
okay h87 very tough to tell i mean i
i think i have a slight preference for
the the square one square up
on h6 oh okay just because you you
you're defending both things
yeah that's true that's right see i i
rarely consider that
but that's very marginal
so now i'm wondering if i want to look
at f5 because then i'd have a pawn
a knight and a rook defending a square
that's only defended by
a pawn and a rook
ah okay
well i sorry i'm i'm more perplexed by
his ridiculous move that he just played
yeah that's uh how to take and then i
i'm also
starting to think about you know a6 b5
and knocking that bishop somewhere else
so that yeah so this is this is a good
spot you're down 90 seconds so you've
got to come up with a quick decision
a decision that's not too committal
so don't fall behind on time too much i
think i'm going knight c5
okay
okay knight c5 no knight c5 is is a
reasonable move no but you're gonna
again you get to position you got to
move your pawns
so now is is another thing it's it's
it's a it's a
game on the clock yep so it's you you
wanna like you wanna look at his time
like all right he's really thinking let
me play a couple quick moves that don't
do anything
so now could be a six b set b5
or also putting my queen on d7 and
putting another defender on the f5
square maybe
yes queen d7 and or queen even up one
more to d6
uh and and constantly monitoring the
pawn trade so you have f5 as a
possibility
and c6 like pawn c6 could potentially
uh trade off the pawn in the center but
that would open up his bishop so i'm not
sure that
that's necessarily i guess i i need to
figure out whether
f5 is is an important square here and i
want to put another defender on it by
putting the queen on d7
or put the queen on d6 well i was
actually a little perplexed because i
thought you moved your king in order to
play the pawn to f5
yeah i did and i got away from it but
then a6 b5
by the way notice his time yep he's he's
down to you know it's within 30 seconds
okay does that move have a threat
first question well yeah i mean in a
sense it's it's another defender of the
f5 square so if i wanted to add another
one
i would have to uh do queen d7 okay but
it's a little too elaborate queen f1
and the rook on f3 are attacking what
this pond
yes so he's just straight up threatening
ah rook takes f7
so maybe queen e8 that's very defensive
but what about that f
f pawn push let's do it sounds like as
good a time as any
yes right now is the the moment moment
you got to play queen eight respects
this thread but
now now you can play f5 and it's uh it's
craziness
and am i looking to take back with the
pawn i think so
if you like it you like it pawn and
knight and even rook all okay
so you trust your instinct now that
trade what does it do to the position
well it opens this diagonal now
where the bishop on b2
and my bishop and king have just this
pawn in the middle
although it's not immediately affected
not immediately affected absolutely
right um
i have this interesting idea actually
that i don't know if it works of playing
e4
and i would be attacking the defended
bishop on b2
and the rook but i don't know if it
really gets me too much i imagine the
rook would move
yeah and also the bishop can take you
with a check
right and then i just have to take back
and then the night the king gets kind of
exposed
yes but you're coming up with the right
idea now remember that
that that subtlety from the the game
that we analyzed prior
which was uh the g
file is now open this trade opens up the
g file yeah rook to g8
would be an interesting one exactly uh
rook to g8 ideas
your queen can come up two to d6
and then to the left to g6 right
uh not too far left though um i'm sorry
today i'm getting more loose with the
political references so by the way
so there's two attackers now on the e5
pawn which means we can play which move
which i will
quite literally just just look at the g8
how do we defend e5 um we play it by
um queen to d6
queen to d6 yes and we do have we do
have fun to e4 which also would defend
uh the threat on e5
while attacking while attacking yes the
only drawback of that move whoops
just almost oh careful destroyed my own
desk
um yeah
but the only drawback would be that your
king would have to come out a little bit
i'm looking if possible very strongly
and powerfully
at rook to g8 next
g8 i'm loving it uh his bishop on c4 is
pretty garbage and his knight on d2 is
not leaving a strong impression so so he
goes rook
to g3 i don't know if that dissuades me
or or
or not or whether i even just play f4
okay although then i could get a little
crazy on this diagonal that my king and
bishop are on
okay so you have you actually have all
the puzzle pieces ruchi iii does have a
threat
yeah the threat is to just take your
bishop
right it looks like it's not a threat
but what but what happens if you take
back with the king um
the bishop used to guard the pawn in the
center
the pawn goes and i can't take it with
the queen because then i lose the queen
yeah i'd say it's it's actually that's a
great move by by the guy you might have
to just move your bishop up
one square so this is
a very high level move rook g3 that's
that's a very nice find then i don't
know if he sees it i could have just
told him all the uh
so i moved the bishop rather than
defending it with the rook because he
can just still take
that's the problem yeah if you do it so
it's one of those spots where you just
your brain is like he can't take it but
and the g8 square is defended also
not just by the king and the rook but
also by the knight yeah it's a
i think it's the most defended square in
your position yeah
she hates square so yeah rook gee is
coming next so
um okay well hold on again let's not get
tunnel vision
does he have a threat well there's
another attacker on the e5 pawn now
there's three attackers
yeah how are you gonna defend it um
what about uh what about e4
potentially play it great move you got
three minutes so we can't you know you
had knight d7 as well
bringing the c5 knight back but uh yeah
e4 is great now now pandemonium is
happening now if the bishop takes
do i take with queen or rook i think
queen
okay so you think queen what's the
difference between the two or can you
not see it
well i'm i'm leaving the rook
i'm i'm only potentially needing to move
the rook once to get it over to g8 if i
decide i want to
okay but
what could i be missing there
you get stuff to tell because with three
minutes all right he's done it so we've
got to make a decision we can't spend it
too much i think queen
okay let's play queen let's see what it
runs into all right rook was better
was better okay all right it's good to
know but but but i'll tell you why your
queen was also attacking his rook
oh okay and yes and so
when you oh god oh my god you got to be
kidding me
so no it's not yeah so so that's no but
but again like i
i i'm not gonna say everything so it's
it's these little things okay knight d2
so what was your game plan here so i
think i
go uh i put the rook on g8 okay that's
the plan
let's yeah this is who i take with the
knight i think with the knight or
actually no the other rook i prefer
the rook looks pretty nice oh that was a
good move i was hoping he wasn't gonna
see that so what's the threat
the threat is
i mean i think i just have to take it
with the pawn i'm not sure good threat
so well the thing is he's gonna take
your rook but it's okay because as we
already learned
you're gonna get a bishop and a pawn for
it so it's not the end of the world king
knight maybe
king a little better but okay tough to
and uh he's got okay he's attacking our
knight um i think i go to e6
probably i like that move i think it's a
good move
yeah time trouble is is a is a pain oh i
was hoping you wasn't gonna see
that okay what about a check on d4
go for it great move make some mason
play a nice uh
and then maybe d5 i'm looking at that's
a that's a nice move get out of the pin
with a check the knight is still hanging
he's in oh but he finds it the other way
i think maybe knight to
g6 okay but i'm gonna urge you
when his knight moves what's hanging
um when his knight moves what's hanging
in your position oh the other night
uh the other yeah the other night so
maybe
maybe i move the king to f7 get it
closer to things
perfect excellent like that's as good as
you can do in this time travel somehow
he's finding every single good move
which is annoying
um now knight six now you can go for
your knight g6
but uh yeah i mean time is going to play
a huge role all right
you might not even have to confirm with
me you'll have to just play some moves
because you have 90 seconds
oh ben feingold just raided me that's cr
now i'm really distracted
[Laughter]
well we got to make him proud i'm gonna
make him proud okay
i think maybe
here now i'm just going on instinct i
think that was a disastrous move
ah this guy is just so annoying he finds
every good move but so you're finding a
lot of good moves too all right so
okay oh boy this is not so good
it's it's it's okay you've got you've
got one last trick maybe
okay well here we only have one move
which is easy to find
it fell apart it fell apart no it's
still like it's not over that's the
thing you lose you lose but like
it's it's it's not over i thought knight
h4 was possible to threaten mate on g2
oh okay that was my okay so this is not
complicated it's a check
so good great run to the side i love it
i love it that's what you have to do
it's the most practical approach
i don't know why i'm getting a random
challenge from like a 1200 but
oh no keep running yep
and sometimes in time trouble your king
will get to safety because they won't
find the best approach
keep it going uh i think maybe here
oh no that was a bad idea
that was a bad idea ah he saw this guy
yeah oh man
so let me let me go back and look at
that actually so i think that i actually
um
at the very end there hold on it should
have been
king to um d5
i yeah i'm trying to figure out yeah
probably king d5
i mean make no mistake about it it is
losing but yeah
it's he's got to find the win
right uh he's got it he's got to find
the win
um so let's see where did it really go
bad
yeah let's actually see where it went
bad
so let's let's according to this rook g8
was a disaster
by you it didn't like rook g8
yeah it went from me up 3.7 to me
down one okay but wait wait exchange on
g8 yeah
it oh because of d6 though because of d6
that's why
yeah okay so what was the better move
instead of rook to g8
um the better move instead of rook to g8
was
queen to h4 maybe i don't know
maybe check on d4
yeah that seemed to sort of hold steady
it seems i fall a little further behind
but
oh my goodness wait i just i i just uh
yeah i booted up the computer and uh
well again this is why
practicality of engine play is
ridiculous
um it's the rook on g3
you can trap it you can play pawn to f4
do you have that position yeah i do i do
yeah f4
and if the rook moves up one square you
attack it with the h pawn
and it's trapped right
but like wow okay you know but it also
wasn't
just that this was better i i i it
looked like i l it was like a
a swing of like three and a half putting
that rook on g8
yeah because of the d6 idea the the
breakthrough that he found there
um yeah was uh was was was really the
issue
um and then he he found b4
and he had he took the pawn and you i
mean you play you played quite well like
consolidating the position
one last trick on move oh by the way
when i took the when i took the bishop
on g8 with the king
it also found that to be disastrous it
wants you to take with the knight yeah
oh no it actually wants you to look at
this it wants you to disregard that and
throw in a check
on d4 with the queen that's what it
wants
that's actually oh yeah it seems to say
oh
okay yeah it does say it's best but yeah
right and then the king has to get out
of the way
yeah it actually so king gets out of the
way is one option the other thing is
that if the queen blocks
um then you just trade the queen and so
here's the difference his knight can't
take that central pawn with the trick
right so you'll take his bishop and then
you'll play this is a tricky end
game if you if you get you know two
nights and
one pawn versus you know rook and night
yeah
especially if you bring your pawns
forward and then use your king so
um so what did we learn here
okay well first i mean i think certainly
it was good to play through that opening
with
with another version of the different
ways that it can go in the move order
right if we talk about the specifics um
a lot of it is building your chest
instinct
yeah and i mean that's what chess is so
you actually
if you have it on open on your end on
move
14 can you plug yep
so when he took back on f3 with the rook
yep you have a cool rerouting idea here
with the e7 knight
okay you can go knight to c8 next to
your queen and do you see where you're
going next
um am i bringing the queen out no you're
gonna bring the knight in front of the
other knight to d6 oh i see
okay so if there's just some move here i
don't know what the move would be it
doesn't matter something like this
knight to d6 yes knight to d6
um and so your knights are very strong
his light squad bishop is kind of out of
the game and then you're gonna start you
know conducting your
your attack with your f-pawns um
i kept asking you the question every
move
what is that attack and i just want you
to start like
that will help you so much because one
what is that attack
right his next move what is that attack
um we're seeing certain things repeating
like when he attacked your dark squared
bishop
it's another tactical opportunity that's
wait a second he can take that right
like it doesn't look like he can take
that but he can take that so a lot of
this is vision for our opponent which i
feel like
you you might not you might not realize
it but
watching you play coming up with ideas
moved by move
i mean i see like everybody in my chat's
like what the hell this guy's like the
strongest 1000 we've ever seen
um how do i lose every game then that's
crazy
well that's like that's actually that's
actually a thing that happens to a lot
of people people say i'm studying chess
all the time and i'm losing more or i
can't finish games and
uh yeah i mean you know oftentimes
people have the knowledge theoretically
but putting it all together in a game
from start to finish they just can't
i mean they can't do it every single
time yeah you know so
right i mean so but in all seriousness
though
even though i don't think i'm winning
i'm not winning more games
i feel like i'm definitely identifying
the mistakes much more
uh quickly and understanding what
happened
rather than just wondering like it's
less of a blur where i'm like what the
hell just happened it's like i'm much
more
it's much clearer where things went bad
which i think is something
it def definitely is something uh and
just just looking at some of the way you
know some of the ways you're coming up
with ideas
you're you still have a couple small
blind spots about
scanning for their checks right like
scanning for you know their attacks
which did happen a couple times this
game but
um just start asking yourself that
question a little bit more in the 10 and
15 minute games that you're playing
uh and it's going to be it's it's going
to make things a lot easier
yeah i mean just in general i'm not
usually thinking through
what is the next move that my opponent
is looking to do
which i should be asking myself much
more right
yeah it's it's it's what do they want
like yeah
if you figure that question out you're
gonna win a ton of chess games because
that's what chess is all about like at
the highest of levels
it's two people both seeing what they
think are the best moves for each other
and evaluating them constantly it's not
oh i'm gonna come up with this plan and
he's not gonna see it
you know so uh that's that that's really
what it is it's like i know that's his
plan
is it good should i shut it down how do
i come up with my own idea
yeah or can i put together a stronger
attack more quickly
yes exactly and then there's kind of
this mental conversation yeah
um what's uh what's what's your game
plan what's your once your next
are you going to do the same circuit me
bowties and then and then i'm sorry me
rosenberg says
i mean it seems like a pretty good
circuit i have to tell you
you got some good coaches yeah yeah yeah
no i should and then but
what really i need to figure out is
what's my off stream
um routine so to speak like should i be
basically trying to do
three games a day and a bunch of puzzles
is that i mean
is that reasonable i don't know yeah try
to do try to do uh
three games a day and well here's the
thing
like don't kill yourself before the
tournament like that's the thing like
don't don't do
too much yeah uh
work before the actual tournament itself
you'll be exhausted like the people are
going to come in with
you know much fresher doing you know
some lessons uh
a couple times a week and that's it so
do what you find you know is nice take
some breaks
three games a day is good and puzzles
try to get 10 out of 10.
i think i told you that only do 10 oh
okay and try to get 10 out of 10.
10 puzzles try to get them all yeah it
doesn't matter how long it takes if it
takes you six minutes
fine like get it right
work through all the little things and
and try to go for 10 out of 10. don't go
like you know
12 out of 36 or something right or or
20 out of 40 like gotcha and i think we
still we're still like a month out
doesn't it aren't the first games august
26th or something i don't even know when
it is
okay well you just announced something i
guess because i didn't know that um
no i i'm not actually sure yeah three to
four weeks yeah
three or four weeks okay so we're about
a month out yeah oh
21st some people are saying okay oh i
have less time than i thought
yeah no i mean hey some people are not
doing any lessons
yet oh is that right i think you're in
good shape for now yeah okay yeah and
i do also have by the way there's people
in my audience who have been
watching the other lessons so far and
communicating to me what's going on it's
been of no use
what uh whatsoever so far but at some
point there may be something specific
like
somebody's playing an opening a lot or
who knows well uh yeah i know like uh
itsafu has been playing a ton
and um she streams a whole variety of
different games but yeah she's taking up
the chess every time she's streaming
she's streaming chess for puzzles rating
i think it's 1300.
um that's roughly where i am i don't
actually know who that is but what is
what does she typically stream uh
different i
i dare not say the wrong game i i don't
know to me all the video games are kind
of a
giant mesh except overwatch is the only
video game that i actually
play um but yeah uh she she's been doing
a ton of work so
i don't know i don't know it's gonna be
really interesting because because
uh finton easy with asus is also quite
strong um
you're quite strong she might get quite
strong really fast so
we'll see it's a lot of good players in
this one where should be a real party
yeah and and by the way where are you on
regardless versus irregardless have you
taken a position on that
uh regardless you're for regardless yeah
but is it is it the same word and are
both valid
yeah i think grammatically speaking yes
right i mean i feel like
yeah i think both are valid that's fair
uh all right very good well listen i i
continue to appreciate your time i
appreciate the raid from grand master
benjamin feingold um there's just a lot
of things
happening and i'm going to keep working
here i am actually taking this
relatively seriously and i just don't
want to end
i don't want to embarrass myself really
that's the thing
let us do that we the chess players do
that on a daily basis
so i feel like it would be bad for my
political broadcasting career
if i was a disaster in the tournament i
don't know why i'm linking the two
ah potentially yeah potentially how can
we really trust this guy if you couldn't
even win a beginner's chess tournament
that's exactly right how can i analyze
the senate
if i got scholars mated you know what i
mean like imagine if after six weeks i
get scholars mated and then it's like
dude
we don't care about your senate
prediction we don't care about you know
it and it
all goes down the toilet at that point i
will probably have to just say that i
wasn't the one that was doing the
coaching
you know i'll just delete the vods i'll
remove that ones on youtube that's a
whole other thing i don't want to
embarrass you guys so
yeah it's i'll let rosen and botez uh
take take the fall on that one
yeah um no but no i'm i'm very much
looking forward to it uh
ten yeah ten a day if you want three is
is good and like just actually to to
grind like that and um
yeah i think we'll we'll reconnect soon
all right very good uh
appreciate everybody in your uh your
stream tolerating me for a couple hours
they they love it because they they see
potential in their own abilities
well if i can be an inspiration to
someone that that's good
all right levy thank you i'll talk to
you soon okay cool have a good night
all right see you later all right there
it is uh levy rosman
i believe we've made progress i believe
we've made progress i saw a few
different uh things come
through am i having another chess
tournament
before um pogchamps
probably not because i mean listen
maybe i'll do it here's how i would do
it if my coaches
wanted to play in a tournament between
now and pog champs i would do it
but otherwise i think i'm going to focus
on training and there's just so much
else going on we've got conventions
coming up and all of this different
stuff
any news about me getting a tesla
nothing to announce yet
but let's just say there are many fans
of the david pakman show
at boston area tesla
they're not really dealerships i guess
we would call them
showrooms if you go into a tesla
showroom in the boston area
and you throw around the name david
pakman
anything could happen anything could
happen um we are
just 10 followers from 40 000 on twitch
which is actually potentially a really
great
uh a really great milestone i do want to
thank a few people who have signed up
i'm not going to update this because i
don't have that running but
carlos murphy grabbed a membership
during the chess stream
jacob have to marry him grabbed a
membership
during the chess stream and alan
meraftion
marafshin i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly also grabbed a membership so
there was no big membership
push uh during this stream but i
appreciate that
and i am almost positive there will be a
stream tomorrow in addition to clips in
addition to the podcast and the entire
thing
so i'll see you guys then
[Music]